bonjour william juliet merci d'être
heures en direct avec nous sur rt france
la justice britannique ac est donc rendu
un verdict qui donne raison aux états
unis quelle est votre réaction ce matin
de la première réaction c'est de
souligner que les avocats de julian
assange vont de façon certaine
exercer la dernière voies de droit
possibles pour contester la décision de
la cour d'appel ce n'est pas terminé il
ya encore la possibilité pour les
avocats de julian assange de former un
recours devant la cour suprême anglaise
si les américains avaient perdu il
aurait eu la même possibilité donc il y
à un nouveau délai qui va s'ouvrir il
faut rappeler que
julian assange a déjà fait l'objet d'une
procédure d'extradition concernant le
volet suédois à l'époque de la faire et
que la cour suprême avait là aussi été
saisis et s'était prononcé pour donner
une indication de tenait justement dans
un délai à peu près de six mois
postérieurement à la décision de la cour
d'appel anglaise qui à l'époque avait
également décider de son extradition
donc on peut s'attendre à peu près à une
période d'au tour de six mois pour que
la cour suprême se prononce et si à ce
moment là la cour suprême confirme le
principe de l'extradition julian assange
se rapprochera encore plus à ce
moment-là de d'une remise vers les états
unis en tout cas les partisans de julian
assange se sont mobilisés ce matin on le
voit en direct sur ces images qui nous
parviennent de londres
ça fait maintenant dix ans que cette
affaire n'est toujours pas terminée
yat-il volonté justement voilà de
laisser traîner un petit peu on va dire
julian assange dans cette position on
sait que à plusieurs fois
voilà les militants de julian assange
mais aussi les militants des droits
humains ont alerté sur la situation du
lanceur d alerte en prison
je crois pas qu'il ait une volonté des
autorités judiciaires anglaise de faire
traîner quoi que ce soit la justice
extraditionnel comme on l'appelle
anglaise est une des justices les plus
pointilleuses au monde les procès en
extradition notamment en france sont
gérés en règle générale avec une
attention moins importante en termes de
jours d'audience notamment
je crois que la justice anglaise prend
le temps d'examiner tout ce qu'elle doit
examiner c'est un processus en est celle
qui est long aussi parce qu'il ya comme
je le rappelais tout à l'heure des voies
d'appel des voies de recours et que afin
que un dossier viennent à son terme et
bien ça prend ça prend du temps alors
évidemment du côté de julian assange qui
reste détenu et bien cette un temps qui
me paraît extrêmement long du côté des
américains c'est un temps qui paraît
sans doute aussi long avant d'obtenir un
déroulement éventuellement favorable et
de pouvoir de leur point de vue enfin
pouvoir commencer des poursuites
effective effectifs pardon contre contre
la personne réclamée
la justice britannique qui va donc de
nouveau devoir statuer sur la demande
d'extradition américaine est ce que elle
peut aboutir cette cette demande
américaine
écoutez on se rapproche en effet d'un
aboutissement il faut aussi rappeler que
le jugement de première instance avait
refusé l'extradition de julian assange
mais pas sur le point à dire que tout le
monde attendait aussi parmi peut-être
vos collègues sur la question de la
liberté de la presse juge de première
instance avait pris une décision contre
julian assange en indiquant qu'il
estimait que l'extradition était
possible au vu des questions liées à la
liberté de la presse ils ont vu des
questions liées à ce que ses avocats
dénoncé comme étant une motivation
politique des poursuites
cet argument n'avait pas performé et
l'extradition avait été refusée par le
juge uniquement sur la question des
risques qu'encourait julian assange au
vu de sa santé notamment le niveau de sa
santé mentale dégradée en cas
d'extradition et ce qui s'est passé là
devant la cour d'appel c'est que les
américains ont apporté des garanties
diplomatiques supplémentaires en plus de
celles qui avaient été accordés en
première instance en prenant des
engagements de ne pas par exemple
confiné julian assange à l'isolément de
ne pas l'envoyer vers la prison de haute
sécurité du colorado et que au vu de ces
éléments là le juge d'appel a considéré
que les risques qui avait été retenue
par le juge de première instance n'était
plus constitué de la même façon donc on
va voir ce que la cour suprême dit mais
le voilà être clair que judiciairement
julian assange se rapproche et bien
d'une décision de remise vers les états
unis comme je le disais en introduction
on sera fixé sur ce point là sans doute
d'ici à peu près six mois le combat de
julian assange est ce que on peut dire
que finalement c'est aujourd'hui un
combat pour la liberté de la presse
aussi
écouter tout dépend du côté duquel on se
place j'interviens aujourd'hui on va
dire un petit peu comme consultant je
suis pas parti à ce procès si on se
place du côté américain et bien on va
considérer que des fautes ont été
commises au delà du travail
journalistique
on va dire classique et que c'est cet au
delà qui doit être poursuivi puis du
côté de julian assange
on dénonce au contraire des poursuites
politiques par les états unis
c'est souvent comme ça dans ce type de
procédures sensibles extraditionnelle il
y a dans ce dossier tout de même des
éléments
je dois quand même le souligner qui pose
question sur la position américaine et
notamment
des éléments liés à l'implication de la
cia on sait qu'il y a eu
des événements qui se sont déroulés
notamment en espagne avec une société de
surveillance qui avait été
instruite par l'agencé américaine pour
surveiller julian assange dans
l'ambassade à londres d'équateur il ya
des faits qui sont quand même
extrêmement préoccupant qu'ils n'ont pas
rapport forcément directement avec le
sujet que vous évoquez de liberté de la
presse mais il ya autour de ce dossier
des éléments semble t'il probant
laissant penser que les américains aient
bien ont tenté d action
réalisé des actions ou envisager
d'autres actions il a même été question
un moment de complot pour assassiner ou
enlever julian assange et il semblerait
que des éléments probants et été produit
en ce sens ça pose des questions
inquiétantes dans ce dossier là et puis
également peut-être dans d'autres
procédures on verra ce que la cour
suprême on dit en tout cas je crois en
effet que ce dossier pose des questions
extrêmement sérieuse pas seulement au
niveau juridique mais également au
niveau est bien de certaines pratiques
qui peuvent se faire jour par certains
états lorsqu'il poursuivre
l'exécution
d'une remise d'une personne que ce soit
à des moyens judiciaires ou comme on l'a
compris la part des moyens extra
judiciaires merci beaucoup en tout cas
où il y avait à jullié d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialisé en droit pénal droit
de l'homme et extradition